j'aime beaucoup françois hollande j'ai
été son minier j'étais le directeur de
sa campagne présidentielle et je suis un
social démocrate mais sur l'europe
j'aurais aimé je les dis et je le lui ai
dit qu'il aille plus loin qu'il aille
plus fort qui ne se contente pas de
mentionner ces sujets mais qu'il fasse
un grand discours
un grand discours entraînant de volonté
de propositions à l'allemagne il ne l'a
pas fait avant de cette façon là
assurément emmanuel macron être un pas
devant va plus loin et je trouve ça très
bien que le président ne réplique
française soit capable d'avoir cette
parole forte
on l'attendait c'est pas le retour de la
france en europe la france est elle à ce
qu'a fait françois hollande sur la grèce
était remarquable mais il fallait un
discours plus systématique remarques
pour emmanuel macron ont plutôt pour
vous par rapport à ce que vous dites d'
emmanuel macron on ne peut pas dire que
ça marche il faut attendre pour
l'instant nous avons les propositions
des manuels manon nous avons une
proposition dans le bunker et je suis
d'accord et avec emmanuel magnien passé
avec jean claude juncker il faut un
budget de la zone euro pour réduire les
divergences au sein de la zone euro
qu'il faut un ministre des finances de
la zone ans qui soit aussi commissaire
en charge des affaires économiques
mon post d'aujourd'hui pour animer et
piloter la politique honni de la zone
euro et un contrôle parlementaire
exercée par le parlement européen
mais croyez moi on est encore loin du
bout ça d'abord apprendre d'abord
j'attends que les propositions
françaises soit encore plus forte et
précise mais ça va venir
et puis il faudra aussi voir comment les
autres réagissent à commencer par les
allemands donc ne faisons pas comme si
les carottes étaient cuites